foreign
is the second rarest Rare Earth least
abundant the only one that is even less
common is Promethean which is
radioactive and we can't use it here
I'd never seen thulium but our friend
Anthony Lipman produced a really nice
lump for us I have to say that is a
really nice sample and it has given the
best
Bunsen test
that any of us have seen before
so before we get to that
a few facts
though Lim was discovered
in 1879 by a Swedish chemist called
clever or maybe cleave I don't know I
can't speak Swedish it wasn't isolated
till sometime later
because purifying these elements is
extremely tedious
they had to recrystallize something not
once not twice not a hundred times not a
thousand times but more than ten
thousand times
which says real devotion or Obsession
depending which way you think about it
but we didn't have to do that our
thulium came through the post and I got
really excited some years ago we were
sent a video of a six-year-old periodic
videos fan Winston who got some thulium
for his birthday present
I found
that's all we're having this cabinet
I didn't get quite that excited but I
did send Brady an email the interesting
thing about thulium is that it is
moderately reactive in the sense that it
will dissolve in Weak acids like dilute
sulfuric acid
I mean weak in terms of concentration
not that sulfuric acid is a weak acid
and it makes a slightly cloudy solution
and it generates hydrogen
it was quite fun because the cork on the
test tube kept on popping off
foreign
had enjoyed himself demonstrating that
you got a pop when you lit the hydrogen
but what's really quite interesting
about thulium salts is that they're
fluorescent
if you shine ultraviolet light on it
the thulium ions absorb the UV light
which loses some of its energy while
it's absorbed in the atom and then is
the light is given out in the visible so
it's easy to see so Brady's camera can
see it there was too much light in
Neil's lab
and we had to go into his office quite
exciting
and his office has no outside windows so
it was really quite dark
and they're in front of the UV light the
solution glowed a sort of pale blue I
suppose and
Neil was very pleased we then took that
solution back to the lab and Neil and I
thought perhaps we should test them with
some of his favorite Solutions of course
the solution was still quite acid so
Neil diluted it a bit with water
and then divided it up into several test
tubes
and the first test tube he added some
potassium carbonate
and there was some bubbling presumably
because the carbonate was reacting with
the acid but then a not very exciting
white precipitate
of thyolium carbonate we then tried
sodium sulfide which gave also a not
very exciting weight precipitate and the
smell of Bad Eggs which Neil didn't like
I warned him beforehand there'd be a
smell
and then finally we used our favorite
potassium dichromate
and in the acid it changed color but we
got a moderate precipitate we may be the
first people who've ever seen
thorium chromate because it's not a very
common compound
[Music]
but then the exciting part kneel and
Connor started filing some thulium to
get very finely divided particles
a nail sprinkled them
into the Bunsen Flame
and that was when the real surprise came
the burning particles gave out a huge
amount of light rather greenish
but also quite a strong crackling noise
we came away feeling that thulium was
really much more interesting than we
expected it's called thulium because
it's based on an ancient Greek name
for somewhere in the north so it has
strong Scandinavian connections possibly
Iceland or somewhere in that region and
originally it was proposed that it would
have the symbol t u
I'm not sure why it was changed to TM
possibly because Tu is the French word
for you there may be some completely
other reason
but I think TM is quite a nice symbol
special thanks to all our supporters who
appear on our Periodic Table of patrons
if you'd like to give us a little bit of
extra help you can appear here too we
even hang versions in the professor's
office and Neil's lab details in the
video description
either way we appreciate everyone who
supports us just by watching maybe even
telling your friends about us check all
the usual places to see even more of our
videos one's first reaction is that it
can't possibly be real because normally
you don't see such things